started again so this time we have a
pre-recorded talk by Ron Steinfeld he he
is at Monash in Australia as you can see
and it's a three 3:20 a.m. there so you
know you know this is I think we've had
two talks by you know people in the US
and in Europe and in Israel in the past
workshops and this is by far the lot
the largest sort of geographical
distance but that we have had to our
server encounter so we'll have to make
do with a pre-recorded talk what that
means is that you know you you can still
ask questions but I suggest that you
type it out in the Q&A interface and
will transmit all these questions to Ron
and and so he'll get back and we'll find
a way to sort of get these answers back
to you and and yeah with that you know
he was wrong in virtually okay so
following on from the previous talk that
introduced CC encryption in the kyurem
I'm going to talk now about our recent
work on devising tighter theorem proofs
I mean how to use them to avoid the
square root advantage loss and so this
is work this is based on joint work to
appear at your crypt 20 with Veronica
couch I mean sex ed and shipping son
from Monash University and Damian Stella
from Innes Lyon so I'll start by
reviewing quickly some of the background
since it was already discussed in a
previous talk about the foodie sake
Okamoto transform from sofia to CCA and
the theorem for security proofs and then
i'll focus on the one way to hiding
lemma which is the core ingredient in
these security proofs for CCA security
in the theorem and
I'll talk about the previous approach in
Prior proofs of this lemma that I call
query based secret extraction proofs and
I'll explain why they inherently suffer
from the square root advantage loss
limitation so to do that we'll look more
into the quantum origins of the square
root loss that was first pointed at by G
and L last year and why this kind of
extraction I cannot avoid this square
root advantage loss and then I'll
introduce a new technique for one way to
hiding lemma and proof that avoids this
limitation and we call it to measure
rewind measure or mrm technique for one
way to hiding and our idea is to use a
different way to extract the secret best
which I call the measurement based
method rather than query based I should
say that Janet L called the query what I
call query based I called measurement
based but I'll explain why I called our
new technique measurement based and
their technique or the old technique the
query base technique and then I'll
present our main one way to hiding lemma
that avoids the square root loss and
explained some of the main ideas and
will I'll then explain how we apply this
new lemma to get improved tighter proofs
for the Fujisaki Okamoto cci secure
encryption in the theorem that also
avoid the square root advantage loss and
for this proof we also need to assume an
amount
injectivity property on the underlying
encryption scheme as well as the
standard kind of negligible decryption
failure property and as a corollary we
obtain new Fujisaki Okamoto CCA security
proofs in the theorem
that are nearly tact for attackers of
low query depth that correspond to
highly parallel eyes the text and I'll
then mention some ongoing work and open
problems so the Fujisaki of carotid
transform has already been introduced in
the previous talk so it's very commonly
used to strengthen CPI to see CIA
security for public key encryption so
the idea is that we start with a CPA
secure scheme and transform it with this
fr transform into a CCA secured scheme
when this kind of transform is used by
most practical cci secure schemes for
example most of the nist
pic you see candidates for post quantum
public key encryption use this method so
we will focus in this work on a
particular variant of Fujisaki Okamoto
that is denoted with the perp and the
line threat and as explained in the
various talk this corresponds to a
variant in which instead of explicitly
rejecting cipher texts that are in the
tikrit incorrectly or that are rejected
instead of rejecting them explicitly
with an error message the decryption
algorithm returns a kind of
pseudo-random output for those invalid
cipher texts but the main idea is that
it uses two hash functions H and H prime
and they are used in two different
transforms the T transform and the you
transform and if you recall from the
first talk the heights prime transform
is used to to make the scheme
deterministic by deriving the randomness
from the message and the second function
H is used to hash the message in the
ciphertext to produce the encapsulated
key so when we're actually talking here
about key encapsulation mechanisms or
public key encryption schemes that
encrypt a key that can then be used with
symmetric key encryption to encrypt a
real message so our assumptions
for the underlying CPI encryption scheme
are these injectivity and negligible
decryption failure that I'll discuss a
bit more later on so the security proofs
in the Kyurem model the these hash
functions - H prime is random Oracle's
and assume the attacker can make you
queries to them so we've already seen
how in the previous talk how in the
Kyurem the attacker can implement these
Oracle's quantumly and so it's an Oracle
that given an input X encodes the
evaluation of the Oracle at X into the
output register and we can model these
attackers as a sequence of processing
steps denoted by AI that produced the
queries to the Oracle followed by calls
to the Oracle
quanto implementation and these are then
followed by a final measurement that
produces the attackers output so as is
reviewed in the previous talk the
essentially essentially all prior F of
Europe proofs for system security
apart from those that make strong vs
such assumptions on the underlying
scheme which don't apply to most cases
all the rest achieved a non tight
security bound for CCA security of the
Fujisaki Okamoto scheme that is related
to the square root of the advantage of
the CPI scheme so potentially they can
lose a lot of security because of this
square root there is also a loss of
square root of Q where Q is the number
of Oracle queries now in in this work we
will show how to remove the square root
on the advantage but at the cost of
larger factor of Q squared is a
multiplicative cost in the number of
queries but we'll see that even the
cost can be reduced for low depth
attackers so the core tool that is used
in all these security proofs is the one
way to hiding lemma and as you can
recall the idea is that since the FL
scheme computes the encapsulated key K
by hashing a secret input X star to the
encryption scheme then the main argument
used in the CCA security proof is that
if an attacker can distinguish this
hashed key from random then he can
effectively query that function at the
secret X star and so the proof tries to
exploit these two to derive X star and
break the one-wayness of the encryption
by contradicting its one-wayness
security so the quantum variant quantum
random Oracle model variant of the one
way to hiding lemma introduced by hoon
row can be equivalently formulated as a
problem of distinguishing two types of
Oracle's so here the distinguisher a is
given access to a quantum Oracle that
either implements the function H or the
function G so hatch and G are both
random Oracle's and they differ only at
a single point X star which corresponds
to this secret so at this point each of
them evaluate two independent random
strings H evaluates to IH and evaluates
to IG and so the advantage of the
attacker can be defined in this way here
and what one way to hiding lemma states
is that even and is such distinguisher
between these two Oracle's we can devise
an extractor algorithm B that can use a
to efficiently extract the secret X star
and the advantage of B is the
probability that B outputs X star
now the bee itself can have access to
either H or G or or sometimes both as
you see
so the original strategy used by une rue
in order to devise this extractor is
what's called what I call query based
extraction and the idea is simply an
extension of the classical method which
is to do a quantum measurement of random
query of a - it's Oracle and hope that
the result is going to be the secret X
star so owner showed that with this
query based extraction the advantage of
a distinguisher can be related to the
square root of the advantage of the
extractor so we have the square root
loss and there is also a factor of Q
loss working is the number of Oracle
queries now subsequent to work by
actuate in and bend a little last year I
improved this bound by removing the cube
but they still have the square root loss
and to do this they had to use the
double a double sided Oracle in
extraction which means that the
extractor B can access both G and H so
one question you can ask is is this
Square query based extraction and
avoidable the square root loss in in
such query based extraction and Jia ETL
last year showed an impossibility result
that effectively answers this question
in the positive and what they what the
effectively observed is that there is a
fundamental quantum origin for this
square root advantage loss so they
showed that in fact even for just one
query to the Oracle there there exists
such a distinguished or quantum
distinguish or a whose advantages as big
as the square root of the advantage of
the query based extractor and so what it
means is that we cannot help to avoid
this square root loss if we are using a
queer
extractor what our observation in this
work is is that if we look a bit closer
into this distinguisher we can see
actually this distinguish are in fact
suggest an alternative way to do the
extraction rather than focusing on the
queries of the attacker we are going to
focus on the measurement performed by
the attacker in order to do its
distinguishing we call this a
measurement based extractor and the idea
is to extract the knowledge of X star
from that measurement rather than from
just from the queries so that's the idea
of our approach so to understand more
about how it works I'll explain a bit
more about the the quantum distinguisher
shown by ji-yong hotel now i know that
some of you may not be familiar with
quantum computation so I'll try to
explain the main concepts as I go along
to focus on the main ideas so the main
idea of this distinguisher is that the
attacker performs a superposition of
input states where the amplitude
associated to each state is with the
input register being X prime is the
square root of px prime now in quantum
computation if we measure the input
register in such a superposition then we
will get a particular value for the
input register with the probability that
is the square of the amplitude of that
state so in this case the secret X star
has an amplitude of square root of px
star and so measuring the query which is
what the query based extractor does
gives a success probability of px star
and now let's see what happens now in
the attacker makes this query to the
Oracle is going to get one of these two
states
hydrops IG depending on whether the
Oracle is hey Choji
the only difference between these two
response states is the value the
component corresponding to the
evaluation at X star which differs
whereas all others are evaluating to be
the same so in order to distinguish
whether the state excite H or Saji
but this distinguisher does is it makes
what's called a quantum projecting
measurement on the state a projecting
measurement with respect to sub
measurement vector V is just a
measurement that returns a certain value
let's say one with a probability that is
related to the length of the projection
of the state along the measurement
vector but we have to square that length
of the projection in order to get the
probability so in order to understand
the geometry of what's happening here
let's have a look at a diagram of this
situation we see in red the size and in
bloops RG and what you can see that the
difference between these states is this
state that encodes the secret x star and
it's it's length is essentially the
square root of P X star so this is
significantly bigger than the X star and
we want to have a distinguisher that can
distinguish these states with similar
square root advantage but I'll assume
here that still px star is is very small
now you can see that if I were to use a
projective measurement along a vector V
prime that is somewhere here close to
the size H then basically I will get a
projection of size G that is of length
something like a cosine of the angle
theta and so when I square it I get
cosine square and whereas the red vector
will project to
approximately a length of one and so
therefore the advantage the difference
between these squares the advantage of
such a distinguished are using the prime
will be something like one minus cosine
square of theta which is sine square of
theta and basically it's the square of
theta which is very small or px star
it's essentially the same as the success
probability of the query extractor so
this is not a good distinguisher this is
not a way to get a square root advantage
in order to get the the optimal
distinguisher we have to rotate the
measurement vector to this vector here V
at an angle of about 45 degrees and if
we use that optimal distance here you
can see the projections here of science'
H are much bigger and in fact after we
square them and we compare the
difference to get the advantage we see
that although there is a component that
squares the length of Delta there is
also the cross term that multiplies by 1
over square root of 2 so you get a
component proportional to just the
length of Delta which is of the order of
square root of px star so this is why we
can get a square root advantage by using
this optimal distinguisher with about
45-degree angle measurement vector so
this is the square root distinguisher of
Geritol and now i come to our idea what
we do is we actually make a couple of
observations on this distinguisher so
first of all our first observation is
that the measurement vector V somehow
encodes a knowledge of the attacker of
the secret X star and what what I mean
by that is that suppose that we could
get the state of the system to be V then
if we measure the input register in this
state we would get with the high
probability about 1/2 the value of
secret X star and we can see that by
projecting the measurement vector along
the direction of Delta which as we said
before consists has the the value x star
in the input register and so this is the
first observation is that the
measurement encodes the secret and the
second question is how do we get the
system to be in the state V so that we
can make that measurement and the answer
is to use the the what so-called
collapsing property of quantum
measurements what we do is we just let
the attacker perform his measurement
with respect to the measurement V the
vector V and after that measurement is
performed by the attacker the state of
the system will collapse to the to be
the measurement vector V and then we can
perform our measurement of the input
register in the state V and extract the
secret and you can see from this diagram
that projecting the let's say the
attacker makes the he's a measurement
with respect to V on the on the upside G
state then with probability about 1/2
he will get collapsed to the director V
and so overall we get a kind of strategy
for a new strategy for measurement based
extraction of the secret that is
summarized here where we first run the
attacker to output its Oracle query so
this is for the case of one Oracle query
with that optimal distinguisher and we
process the Oracles query with the with
the Oracle G and the state becomes PI G
we then let the attacker perform this
measurement with respect to V the state
will collapse to V with high probability
and then we measure the input register
in the state V and we and will get the
secret X star again with our probability
overall this strategy extracts the
secret with probability about 1/4 so
it's much better than the query based
extractor that only succeeds with
probability P X star now in fact if we
if we were to implement this idea this
extraction idea in in the standard
quantum computational model then in the
standard model an attacker cannot just
perform a quantum algorithm cannot just
perform an arbitrary projective
measurement directly it can only perform
projective measurements with respect to
the so called computational basis and so
in order to perform such a measurement
with respect to V which is not a
computational basis vector the the
attacker actually implements such a
measurement using these three steps
three point one two three point three
here and they basically involved running
a kind of pre measurement unitary that
rotates the state from V to a
computational basis vector then the
attacker makes a computational basis
measurement and then what we do is we we
run the attacker backwards the pi/2 part
of the attacker we run its inverse to go
back to the query phase and these three
operations are equivalent to what we
said before was a projective measurement
on V and so written in this way we see
that in practice what are a new
measurement based extraction is doing is
basically running the attacker to
perform its measurement then rewinding
back the attacker to the query phase and
then measuring again the input register
in order to extract the secret and
that's why we call our technique measure
rewind measure or mrm so this is how it
works in the case of the optimal
distinguisher and what we did is we
showed in fact that it it can
work with a slight variation for general
or non-optimal distinguishes that can
use any vector V that is somewhere
between the optimal one and the bad one
we saw or in fact it can even use more
general measurements with respect to a
subspace of more than one vector rather
than just to one vector V we had in the
previous example it turns out in order
to do this generalization we only have
to change a small part of our extraction
approach that I discussed before and the
main change is that instead of using the
the G Oracle in this step to to process
the query what we do is in the
extraction we instead use what's called
a superposition Oracle of G&H that is a
kind of mixture of the two so basically
the superposition Oracle will compute G
Plus H with an amplitude of 1/2 and G
minus H with a probability of 1/2 and
there is an additional what's called
entangling whitby that differentiates
these two cases so in a general
algorithm we'll measuring will measure
this entangled bit and if it's zero
we'll perform the usual mrm extraction
and if it's one we'll do the original
query based extraction and in our
general analysis of this generalized mrm
technique we show that the advantage of
the one way to hiding a distinguisher
can be rewritten to as an inner product
between the difference of the G and H
States and the sum of the G&H States
projected on the subspace used in the
attackers measurement and we using the
fact that the difference of G n H has
the secret in the input register that's
the crucial property that it means that
this difference is unchanged by a
projection on the
on the secret value in the input
register and using this property we can
rewrite the the inner product by adding
this projector and it doesn't change it
and we can then apply the Schwarz
inequality to to show that these
advantages at most the product of this
term which is the advantage of the
query-based extractor and this one which
is the advantage of the other mrm
extractor you can see now why we used in
our general method the the sum and the
difference in this superposition Oracle
so overall what we get is that the one
way to hiding this thing issuing
advantage is at most the geometric queen
of the advantages of these two query
based and measurement based extractors
and so it's at most the the larger of
the two times at most a factor of four
so this is how this is our main idea and
we generalize this idea further to
handle any number of queries q rather
than just one and the main idea is to
use a hybrid a standard hybrid approach
over the q Oracle queries and show that
the advantage with Q queries is at most
Q times the advantage with one query so
we lose a Q factor loss but we by
looking a bit closer we can reduce this
factor Q to in fact just a factor of D
which is the attackers query depth so
that means that if the attacker makes
many queries in parallel we only count
the the number of such parallel bunches
rather than the actual total number of
queries and it implies that our bound is
tight for low query depth attackers that
corresponds to massively parallel eyes
the tax so this is a statement of our
general lemma one way two hiding lemma
and you can see that it bans the
advantage of the one-way to hiding lemma
but by four times the
where that of the attacker D times the
advantage of the extractor
now we also generalize it to handle
cases where the Oracles can differ on
more than one point rather than just the
point X star in the previous example so
in comparison to the previous one way to
hiding lemma bindle at all we can remove
the square root on the advantage but we
add this extra factor of D or the query
depth and in both cases we the extractor
also uses access to both the H and the G
Oracle's there is also another more
subtle difference in that distinguisher
in our one way to hiding lemma
distinguishes the event were the
distinguisher outputs one between the
two Oracle cases whereas in the previous
work this event it could be an arbitrary
event which is not necessarily
efficiently decidable so to apply this
result to CCI security or for the sake
of konato as I said we because we are
using the double sided extraction Oracle
of GNH in our security in our one way to
hiding lemma we need a CC ID proof that
can work with such one a double sided
lemma and the bindle Attell proof from
last year it uses such a double side
extraction Arkell so RCC ID proof is a
variant of the bindle Adel proof with
with our new one way to hiding lemma
used instead of the the old one of in
the hotel and there is just a slight
variation in the proof in our proof
compared to be in the rattle because we
have to handle is not efficiently
checkable event that that was used in
Binda without proof and replace it with
an application of our lemma 2 to the
event that a outputs one now the the
extra
conditions that we need on the
underlying encryption scheme for for our
CCI proof the the two listed here so the
basic idea is that this kind of proof is
the simulation of the decryption Oracle
is not going to work correctly unless
the underlying encryption scheme the
deterministic encryption scheme is
injective except for a negligible
probability ETA over the choice of the
public key and there is also the
standard property of avoiding decryption
failures that is also needed so the
final statement is shown in this slide
here where we showed that the CCI
security advantage of the foodie sake
Okamoto scheme is related to the
advantage of the in CPA security of the
underlying encryption scheme that we
start with up to without any square root
loss on the in CPA advantage but with a
multiplicative factor that is the
product of the query depth the H of the
H queries and the where depth of the the
other Oracle used in Fujisaki Okamoto
scheme parity so for low query depth
attackers this are bound on CCI security
is nearly tight there are also other
terms that are related to the
injectivity of the scheme so as a final
thing I'm going to tell you a bit about
our ongoing work and some open problems
so first is to improve the tightness
further of our reductions by reducing
the dependence on on the query depth D
and here we we are trying to replace the
hybrid argument that we use to handle
more than one query by some tighter
techniques like those used in earlier
work
and combine them with RM RM to click the
other thing is we want to are looking
into relaxing the double-sided aspect of
our extractor to make it single sided
and remove the injectivity requirement
from our CCI proof and we already have
some preliminary results on the
injectivity analysis and the concrete
implications of our results to the next
DQC encryption candidates and finally it
will be interesting to see what other
applications RM RM technique has so
thank you very much and I'll stop here
transmit so we'll reconvene in in 6
minutes for mark stock marks and restock
mark maybe you wanna set up the slights